rendre les cours d'écoles moins polluer
c'est l'objectif de ce dispositif
innovant installé depuis une semaine
dans la cour de récréation de l'école
victor hugo à poissy dans le cadre de la
journée internationale de l'air pur
lundi 7 septembre la présidente de la
région ile de france le maire de la
ville et la directrice générale adjointe
de suez sont venus inaugurer cette
machine qui permet de créer une bulle
d'air pur pour les enfants ce dispositif
va donc permettre de capter de nombreux
polluants l'équivalent de ceux qui
émettent en moyenne 550 véhicule sur un
trajet franciliens quotidien les
particules fines pm10 et pm2 nmi/pmi
inde
ça va être aussi le dioxyde d'azoté le
no2 et ça va être aussi les composés
organiques volatils mais c'est vrai
c'est les polluants principaux qu'on
retrouve dans les villes et aussi dans
les écoles en juillet 2020 l'état a été
condamné pour son inaction concernant la
pollution de l'air alors pour encourager
ces projets environnementaux
la région ile-de-france a mis sur la
table 500 millions d'euros grâce au
budget participatif environnemental de
la région toutes les communes qui
décideraient de se lancer pour
développer ce dispositif pourront
déposer des projets et pourront se faire
financer ce dispositif
pour ce premier essai l'école victor
hugo en plein centre de poissy n'a pas
été choisi au hasard on en plein coeur
du centre-ville où il ya des milliers
des milliers de voitures qui traversent
la ville comme les poids lourds qui
n'ont rien à faire ici en matière de
circulation de transit on a choisi ici
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de passage et on
veut pouvoir montrer qu'on peut purifier
l'air avec des idées qui sont innovants
ce premier dispositif tests s'ils
fonctionnent pourrait se retrouver
prochainement dans des gares dans les
métros ou dans les aéroports franciliens